You are listening to radio lab radio from w n y s
do you, can I ask you, do you,
do you just want to like lay out for us the chronology of your obsession?
I think I feel comfortable saying it with him.
Has it become an obsession or just a PR? Just a PR.
A dalliance or maybe you just noticed a crumbling building and ran over to stick
your pen. I mean, I, I am, uh, I'm a contrarion
and I'm interested in alternative facts about science. Let's say.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This was radio lab and a little while back our editors, Soren Wheeler and I,
we talked to a science journalist named Dan Engber who got us kind of tangled up
about something that we thought we knew about the world, about ourselves.
Something beautiful as I recall. Yeah.
That we talked about at great length on this show. Okay. Hello? Hello.
And to set that conversation up,
we're going to start with the sky is this glove seal? Yes.
Professor Claude Steele.
I am the Lucy Sterns Ameritas professor of psychology at Stanford University.
We actually had them on the show number of years ago. Sometimes.
I can't remember how many years ago. Yeah, it's been, it's been a long time.
I'm looking at the sheet here and it says 2009 which blows my mind. Yeah,
that was a lot younger man than I know.
And the reason we had him on the show back then was because he had done a study
in the mid nineties that just completely changed the way that we thought about
the power of stereotypes.
Well, my mother was white, my father was African American there,
and they were very active in the civil rights movements.
So you can imagine that race was no distant or passing thing in our life and
family
for Claude growing up. That was just every day dinner table.
Yes, exactly. So the topic is sort of family birthright,
but then years and years later,
midway through his career as a psychology professor,
Claud ran into a demonstration of the power of race that really surprised him.
I got a job offer.
This is in the 80s at the University of Michigan and it was part psychology and
part to administer a minority student program there.
This is called steel in the original program. We ran back in 2009
and I'm in the process. I saw data that surprised me.
What he saw was a troubling trend. Two kids would enter Michigan, one was black,
one was white. They'd come in at the exact same level, same skills,
same sat score.
So theoretically they should do the same when they get to Michigan,
but without fail or almost without fail, after one semester,
the black kid was winding up with lower grades, lower, pretty, pretty, um,
pretty dramatic. At least two thirds of a letter. Grades,
meaning if the white kid got an a,
the black kid who should be getting an a too is instead getting a B or a B plus
significant. It's significant. It's significant. And he also, by the way,
saw this performance gap between women and men when it came to match at the same
degrees degree in advanced math
courses. It was comparable. I learned this as a national phenomenon.
If I was to walk into an endless any college class in the United States,
I'd have a very high probability of finding exactly that
[inaudible]
so I think it's important to put it in context of what was going on at the time.
This is Dan Engber again and he says that that gap in achievement between black
and white students that cloud had noticed.
That was actually a huge topic of conversation at the time.
There was a lot of discussion of what to do about the achievement gap and the
familiar argument is,
well this has to do with a systemic racism and systemic differences in
opportunities that play out through an individual lifespan.
Now that seems right.
It's also daunting because how are we ever going to like cure all of the
socioeconomic disparities in this country,
but then in 1994 different and in many ways very dangerous idea was being tossed
into this debate. Charles Murray coauthor of the book the Bell Curve.
When the Belker came out,
the bell curve intelligence and class structure in American life,
Bell curve argued that one explanation for that achievement gap among others was
genetic and IQ based. Now of course it's not,
but even though there is no scientific backing at all for the idea of genetic
differences like this,
the bell curve was still significant just because of the kinds of conversations
it was creating at the time and the effect that it had on researchers in this
field.
Well,
the bell curve is one point in a long history of that kind of argument that the
difference between groups really is rooted in genetic differences.
Let's just be frank and honest, and if you really can't admit that,
then you don't have the courage needed to be a real scientist. That's,
that's a thumbnail way of describing this experience that I've had being
confronted with with that notion, and this was obviously disturbing to Claude.
Well first on a personal level, in order to be a scientist,
are you supposed to actually be open to the possibility that you and your family
and your whole race have some genetic limitation.
But also because it was so weak, you know,
scientifically it's been very difficult,
impossible to produce anything like definitive data that the differences in test
scores between groups is genetic.
But while the differences between these students that cloud was seeing in
Michigan, clearly wouldn't be explained by genetic differences.
It also didn't seem to him like it could be explained simply by their
backgrounds or their opportunities. Because you take,
let's say a black kid and a white kid at Michigan,
they both have extraordinary scores like you know,
are in the 98th percentile and they're sats.
So the background between the two kids,
whatever it is, has not resulted in, in a difference to that moment in time.
So if going forward and taking a test,
the black kid gets a lower or a lower performance in a course of some sort,
then something must be happening right there, right there.
Something must be happening in the moment.
[inaudible]
there was something there that people didn't understand and that we certainly
didn't understand it.
So he figured he would start with the woman in math issue.
He brought a bunch of women in and a bunch of men
sophomore brought them into the laboratory one at a time,
gave them a half an hour section of the graduate record exam you take if you're
a math major, very, very difficult math. And sure enough,
the women who had all the same credentials coming into that situation performed
dramatically worse than the men.
Worse as in be a couple hundred points in an sat testing difference.
This is a big effect.
So Claude Steele thought, all right, step one complete.
I've got a lab situation that resembles the real world. Good.
Now the next step is to tweak things a little bit.
See if I can mess around with it.
No, normally in these situations,
the test giver has got a little white lab coat on and he brings in a big stack
of cellophane wrap tests. He puts a clock on the table.
It's all, it's all, you know, it's like that's,
it's gonna intimidate almost anybody.
Maybe that's what's happening. He thought, what if I took away the clock,
took away the coat,
and most importantly right before the test I had the test giver.
Instead of saying the normal, I'm going to give you a test pre test thing.
Maybe instead say something like this. Look,
you may have heard that a women don't do as well as men on difficult
standardized math test. You may have heard that,
but that is not true for this particular test.
This particular test does not show gender differences. Never has never will.
He wondered if maybe saying that simple sentence before giving the test would
have an effect
and sure enough,
I wouldn't be here if their performance didn't go up and go up to match that of
the equally skilled men, that performance gap vanished. She look at this thing,
so we raced and did it very quickly.
The same kind of an experiment with African Americans
there. The pretest disclaimer went like this.
This is an instrument that we use to study problem solving and it is not
diagnostic of individuals intellectual abilities.
In other words, this is not a test of your intelligence. I repeat,
not an IQ test,
so just do the best you can and with that simple disclaimer at the start,
same kind of an effect.
The black students and the white students were now equal.
Just recently, Ryan Brown and Eric Day did an even clever treatment.
There is an IQ test which is nonverbal called the advanced progressive matrices
has figures, very abstract.
They got lines crossing that you have to match and so on checks,
it's essentially pattern matching diamonds with dots and totally visual and so
they can, that test isn't as it is as an IQ test.
It's in fact seen as the gold standard of IQ test because it's quilt culture
free. There's no map,
there's no reading because it doesn't involve language or you could represent
the exact same test as a puzzle puzzle puzzle
meaning you can give an IQ test to a bunch of kids and the black students will
perform worse, but if you give that same test, lose the word test,
lose the word I
cute. You just call it a puzzle.
The black participants suddenly jump up in their performance.
Basically we got a reversal. When you represent it as a puzzle,
blacks perform as well as white. They did. Yeah. That's all it takes.
Just change a few words.
Stereotypes are powerful. Okay, that makes sense now.
But in terms of understanding how this works, can you make this tactile for me,
like if the stereotype is having all these effects is like a thing like a
[inaudible], like a little Gremlin that bites make.
When in the test taking process does it actually like do its damage?
That's going to be way open to debate.
What does seem to be clear from the data according to Eric Day and Ryan Brown
and Claude Steel,
is it the Gremlin only seems to appear when the test is sufficiently hard.
If the test is easy, it's important to point out, uh,
these effects don't happen. It's not that the Gremlin is not there. Well,
he walks in with you,
but he doesn't speak necessarily until things get challenging.
As soon as the test gets difficult, that's where the voices kick in,
which means that for most of the tests, everybody's doing about the same.
It's only at problem number 17 the one about co-signs and factorials and
whatever where things start to go wrong,
and at least that's the theory at that problem.
The black student starts to stiffen up a little bit. That's right.
In Claude Steele's measured this. Their blood pressure's elevated,
their short term memory is impaired.
It's that flicker of frustration through their body that wakes up the Gremlin
who starts to whisper in their ear, I don't know if you can do this.
Oh Shit is what they say about us. True. They don't think you can do it.
All the usual stuff and even if the student doesn't believe it,
which is likely so you don't have to believe it.
That's the kind of insidious thing here.
Just the fact that he has now this extra bit of mental chatter,
that little guy whispering, well,
it's a distraction and that makes their performance go down just a little bit.
All of this dialogue is keeping you from being a hundred percent focused on the
task at hand, which is solving these problems.
Who the real subtle power of a stereotype isn't that it prevents you from doing
the thing you want to do.
It distracts you for just the beat from doing the thing you want to do.
And that may be all the difference.
[inaudible]
so that's how we ended the piece that we did back in 2009. Um,
but in the years after Claude did that original study, um,
and the effect which she called stereotype threat became one of the biggest
stereotype threat and most important ideas type threat in all of social
psychology types.
But now some psychologists say stereotypes can become self fulfilling.
Prophecy and card steal.
Ladies and gentlemen is my great pleasure to present clots.
He became a sort of academic rockstar professor Claude Steele,
doctor Claude Steele,
speaking to overflowing audiences at places like Columbia and Cornell.
Welcome Dr Steven
[inaudible].
And this idea of a stereotype threat was shown to be relevant in cases that had
to do with age and socioeconomic status.
There were studies about women playing chess,
men being tested on like social sensitivity.
I mean,
Clyde's work ended up inspiring sort of a whole generation of social
psychologist. Yeah. I mean,
I would say that the original stereotype threat paper by stealing Aaronson,
you know, blew me away,
just spoke to me and it was beautiful and it seemed to offer answers,
uh, you know, to questions that troubled me.
So this is Michael Slick and I'm a professor of psychology at the University of
Toronto. So when did you begin, uh,
if you could give us sort of the cliff notes version of your history with Stereo
type threat in particular? I mean,
I think I was certainly attracted to,
that's that part of social psychology that dealt with prejudice and
discrimination. So I'm Jewish,
I went to Jewish day school and high school and kind of perhaps baked into me
was a desire to, to for, for social justice, um,
and you know, seeing, you know, the evils of prejudice and you know,
how those evils taken to their logical extreme what could happen.
So I was passionate about the topic. I, um,
so it seemed like a very hopeful, um,
sort of explanation that also offered relatively easy solutions to fix.
Sounds like you really came into it with a very social,
political sort of bent to it. Yes, that's right. Uh,
I wanted my work to have an impact. I wanted it to have to change the world
coming up after the break. Michael tries to change the world,
but the world kinda changes him. Him. Yeah.
Hi, this is Vincent Rojas from Norman, Oklahoma.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
I'm former US attorney Preet Bharara
and my new podcast is called stay tuned.
If you look at areas where he is unconstrained,
his behavior is pretty consistently awful. It's about the human side of power.
Those who do not study history are doomed to repeat it.
And those who study policing, no, we don't study history and it's about justice,
fairness and democracy.
I have never had anyone who committed the crime of murder go to prison ever
again. Presented by w NYC Studios, cafe and Pineapple Street media.
Stay tuned is available wherever you listen to podcasts.
Jed, Robert Radiolab,
we're back and we're talking about Claude steals a seminal research on
stereotype threat,
how the threat of a negative stereotype can impact a person's academic
performance. Right. And, uh,
just before the break we were talking to Michael intellect who after getting
into stereotypes or at research,
he went on to Grad school and really focused in on stereotype threat as his
field of choice. Yeah.
So how many studies of stereotype threat did you end up doing?
I would say in the order of like, uh, in terms of number of studies, you know,
20, maybe 15 to 20, something like that.
He did a lot of studies on women's performance in math,
but also just looking at different environments and how they create our
encouraged these stereotypes. And over the course of his career,
he ended up editing a book about stereotype threat. Um,
gave numerous talks on the subject all over the world.
Even signed a brief kind of explaining stereotype threat to the Supreme Court of
the United States.
The supreme court heard the oral argument and Fisher v University of Texas at
Austin, as it applied to the question of affirmative action,
the court will decide whether race used in university and college admission
policies, its constitution. Um, so I, you know, put my name to this, but then
I went to,
he moved to Toronto.
I started my,
my current job at the University of Toronto in 2005,
and while he was there,
he was running a lot of his stereotypes or at research on women in math,
you know,
giving women a test and then doing some intervention to reduce the stereotype
and seeing if there'd be a difference in their test scores and simply put for
the first time, I was not able to consistently show any effect of, of,
of stereotype threat. In other words,
the women who had received this stereotype threat reducing intervention
performed just about the same as the women who hadn't. So I think, um,
when I first got here, I, you know, fail to, to,
to replicate some of these effects. I'm like,
let me go back to the drawing board. Let me think about what is my,
how is my population different?
And his first thought was maybe it has something to do with Toronto. So Toronto,
uh, incredibly diverse. A place like take the freshman psych classes,
he was teaching, we're talking about, you know, a third East Asian I,
third South Asian and only about 15% Caucasian or European Canadian and then a
little bit of everything else.
So he started wondering to what extent do our students even,
how are they aware of these stereotypes about, you know, women in math. Um,
and remarkably when I would ask, you know, our students this, like he'd asked,
who here is heard of the stereotype that women are bad at math? Um,
I would say no more than like a quarter to a third had, you know,
a strong awareness of this stereotype.
So he started running the experiments again,
but I'd only pick those women and men who actually had awareness,
but even then I still then couldn't get the effect. Um, so it's like, okay,
well maybe I'm doing something wrong.
Or maybe like maybe the interventions he was designing weren't reducing the
threat or would these students,
maybe the threat just wasn't that much of a threat in the first place.
But by this time Michael had already done a ton of research on stereotype threat
and you know, like I'm a person who gets bored a rather quickly and I just,
you know,
started at least started losing interest but just a couple of years later. Well,
so, um, things changed
on October 17th, 2011 this one paper was published,
it was a paper called false positive psychology and this paper detailed how just
by doing some very standard practices in psychology research and these
techniques, some of which we're taught explicitly in Grad school,
you could sometimes end up with these sort of ludicrous conclusions.
Yeah. So you're saying there were,
this paper was showing ways in which experimenters could subtly unknowingly
juice their results. Is that essentially what it was set? Yeah, essentially. Um,
so the paper was pointing out that it becomes sort of standard practice that you
know,
when you are researching for some effect like oh how happy people were or how
well they did on a test that you would measure that thing in a couple of
different ways, which is what I said. It's considered a good practice, right?
You want to know one measure captures your construct perfectly so you should
measure that thing and as many ways as possible. Um,
but now what if you find that it quote unquote works.
Your hypothesis has confirmed with one of those measures but it's not confirmed
with three or four of the other ones and it was not uncommon practice at that
point to just, you know,
report the one place where you got an effect when they report the one that
worked.
You could even argue that you were just dialing in exactly where this effect
happens. But the paper,
this false psychology paper pointed out that if you ignore the places where it
didn't work,
that's not really a full picture of what that data actually looked like.
And the data is a whole, if you looked at all of it,
might not actually support your conclusion. I remember reading that. Um,
my jaw dropped. I sent this, this paper,
I circulated it to the other faculty in my department and all of us,
or many of us saw the,
the importance of this paper and we call it an emergency meeting called an
emergency meeting. Yeah. I'll never forget it. I mean, it was,
what does an emergency meeting look like of the faculty on, of, uh,
the graduate students to just discuss the contents of the paper, um,
to see what it meant, what the implications were. And as they talked it over,
they realize that in some ways, probably some of their own work, um,
had fallen prey to the problems that this paper was pointing out. I,
I did see myself in, in some of this, um, and I thought,
you know, wow. Like, well, you know, what has been implicated,
what papers of mine, but papers more generally, uh, have been in,
bucketed in the fields, you know, writ large.
People looked at that paper and everyone thought, oh,
this is Dan Engber again. And according to Dan emergency meetings,
like the one that Michael Inzlicht found himself in were happening all over the
world. You know, this is, this is what we're all doing this stuff.
And now we know from this one paper that it's very,
very easy to turn up spurious findings this way. Yeah, it changed.
It changed everything in part because a group of scientists started thinking,
wow,
maybe we really need to go back and reinvestigate some of the key findings in
our field. They call them high power replication.
So you're just kind of doing the same thing but just with more people.
So they started doing these studies with bigger sample sizes and with strict
rules about what data you were looking at.
They say ahead of time exactly what they're going to do and how they're going to
analyze the data. So you know,
there's no possibility of monkeying around to get the answer you want.
And these attempts to replicate or reproduce, you know,
major findings in social psychology.
And the sort of panic that went along with it came to be known as the
replication crisis replication. It's the cornerstone of science.
There's articles who this week are talking about the reproducibility crisis in
science. It's like, Oh man, what, you know, what is going on here?
Because as they reexamined some of these studies,
facial feedback effect studies that got lots of coverage in newspapers and
magazines and then you'll be taking part in today involves some of these
replications we're failing.
So specifically what got me really into covering the replication crisis was news
about ego depletion.
So this is a whole literature of studies that were all about, um,
how we sort of use up our willpower.
Your original study is you go into a lab and you're presented with a, um,
a dish of delicious fresh bake chocolate chip cookies.
I love the method section of that paper.
They described baking the cookies in the labs so that the smell that would be
around the subject when they come in and they,
they put these cookies out and they say you can't have any cookies and then they
leave you alone with the cookies. And what they found was that, you know,
if someone has to sit there,
I'm resisting a cookie with it right in front of them and the smell is wafting
up their nose as they sit there. Um, if they have to go through that,
it'll actually be much harder for them to complete certain kinds of logic
puzzles. And the argument was you use willpower on task a,
then you tried to do task B and you just won't have a store of willpower in less
later studies found you drank some lemonade in the meantime because sugar,
the argument goes, replenishes your willpower.
So there were sort of like increasingly bizarre elaborations of this original
theory. It ended up working with M and m's ended up working with cookies.
It ended up over the years. Dan says,
this idea that you use up willpower in one place and have less another just
start entering all different corners of our lives.
The insight of that original study was replicated again and again and again for
decades.
But then this group of scientists did this massive effort to replicate the
original study. They had over 2000 um, subjects.
They followed these rigorous rules about like what data they were going to look
at. This is as rigorous a replication as you can get.
And they just found like no effect, basically no effect.
But I guess I still don't understand like how is it that they're,
that they are finding nothing now but,
but before they had a study that was then replicated a bunch of times and a
bunch of different labs, look what I still don't get what's going on?
Well [inaudible] so, so you have that original cookie study? Yeah,
I think it's notable that no other studies that I know have used cookies.
Now I've found studies where mnms were used.
So that just makes me wonder, I'm,
I have no idea how that lab did their study,
but it makes me wonder what would happen if I would ran a lab and I wanted to
reproduce this cookie finding and extend it in a new direction and I kept trying
it with cookies and it just never worked. Let me try it with um,
Charleston Chews doesn't work. Hmm.
Cause it's not hard to resist the Charleston.
Maybe Charleston shoes are not good candy. And I end up, I'm like,
I do it with m and ms and it works. Boom. There's my dissertation,
I publish a paper out of it. So now that's in literature.
And so now ego depletion seems like an even stronger,
more valid thing because it's not just about cookies now it's about cookies or m
and. M's.
My point is that you don't really know how many things were tried and each
individual lab.
Do you think that might be what's happening in these labs is that there's a lot
of trial and error and the error is sort of swept aside and the successes are
offered up and then suddenly you have one more success that bolsters the idea.
Is that what you think might be happening? I think that's,
that is the heart of it.
Whatever the problems are, not with those followup studies.
The big thing was that scientists were continuing to fail at replicating these
big [inaudible] and fairly well known studies like the,
the idea that when you smile it changes your mood or offering you a free no tech
life hack.
The idea presented in one of the most watched ted talks ever that that the way
you sort of hold yourself or stand you make yourself big, you stretch out,
you take up the idea that that could have a measurable impact on your behavior
or even your hormone levels.
That one also failed to replicate and that kept happening with study after
study. And of course, you know, other people would come back and say,
oh the replication effort wasn't done right or you didn't really design it well.
You're seeing a lot of the researchers who have made their careers studying
certain effects, they're just not budging. A few of them are,
but most of them are not budging. So, uh, you just have a forming,
I one researcher described it to me,
it's like a civil war within social psychology is still,
so is stereotype threat now itself under threat is,
is it one of these bodies of research that's being rethought?
Well no one has yet done the big multisite preregistered replication that they
did for ego depletion. The one that like really woke me up to this.
But Dan says there have been sort of smaller scale here and there kind of
attempts to replicate some of the studies and you know,
some of those have failed.
Some studies came out that found that he knew what I tried to Redo.
I tried to do the stereotype threat thing on a big group students and I found
that sometimes the opposite happened when I tried to induce stereotype threat.
The students did better. It's like, I'll show you,
well let me, let me say this.
Maybe this will help there because this is something, you know,
I've thought a lot about from the very beginning.
So when we talked to Claude Steele about all this, um,
he had a couple things to say. First of all,
this research has been dramatically well replicated.
The stereotype threat affect has been demonstrated, you know,
way more times in way more different contexts than really any of those other
social psychology study.
I don't know if there's another, if there's another phenomenon,
it has produced so many demonstration and if you can't replicate one of them or
six of them, I don't know. I wouldn't, I would, that doesn't surprise me.
And he says, you know,
you could even see the failures as just information about, um,
where the effect really applies and where it doesn't.
This is science gradually getting sophisticated enough to help apply it
inappropriate places.
For example,
he says he would only expect the effect to appear in at times when the person is
really invested in what they're trying to do and thus the negative stereotype,
you know really is threatening on top of that he says the kinds of stereotypes
that are actually threatening to a given group might change over time.
If you just exactly replicated what we did 25 years ago.
I'm not sure that the stimuli and the procedures would have the same meaning
with today's college students that they had then.
Now the social psychology is the meanings come from the contemporary moment,
the way the state of the culture at that time.
Yeah,
I mean that is interesting actually that I mean if what this research is doing
is studying like an individual's relationship to like threat and like that's
going to be different depending on who you are because you're going to find
different things threatening where you are or even when you are.
Yeah, I, I don't have,
I don't think I know enough about quote the culture of black students today
versus the culture of black students 25 years ago.
But it wouldn't surprise me that there are some real differences. So I,
I don't put as much stock in the exact replication of experiment a or B as I do
in the conceptual
replication. Is it possible, I mean,
you mentioned there are just hundreds of studies that,
that kind of a circle around the same idea in different ways that is on its
face, very compelling evidence that, you know,
this is a robust phenomenon, but the same time, you know,
there's people who gather all the data together and they say, look, you know,
maybe there's some kind of bias that slips in when people are doing this
research.
So they just keep trying different versions until they get something that looks
like a result. Does that seem plausible to you?
Boy, that's a deeply,
um,
I guess cynical, you know, I
count of, uh, of the scientific literature this big,
it would seem to add to it that doesn't seem highly probable to me.
Didn't seem highly likely. To me,
it's clearly real and replicable under these circumstances is just because
they're not everything doesn't mean they're not strategically important to the
progress of this society.
And in fact,
Claude points out that the stereotype threat is pretty unique in the fact that
many of the studies in this literature are not just in the lab they've been
taken out into the streets with, with real people. That's really where the,
you know,
the tire meets the road is can you actually move the educational performance of
real people in real, uh, school situations.
And Claude sent us actually a list of 37 different studies showing that the
interventions designed to reduce stereotype threat can have dramatic and long
lasting effects on achievement. Now we should say there was at least one case,
a,
there was a study done in 2006 that a researcher tried to replicate in 2011 he
has several hundred students instead of whatever it was,
several dozen from the original study. And he finds it,
the fact is just much smaller than the original 2006 effect.
And then just last year he did it again with more students this time and he got
pretty much nothing.
Is the same guy in the same school system trying to do the same study with you
know, hundreds and hundreds of kids and he came up with nothing.
I'm curious to know at Lehman,
given that replication has become a conversation that you have to unfortunately
contend with. I'm just curious if it's changed your opinion of the work.
No, I mean I, I don't think there's anything that could make me go, oh,
this whole thing is not true.
I mean, I want the truth out there more than I want anything else.
This is the Spencer. He was an early collaborator with Claude Steele,
especially on those studies involving women and math tests.
I did recognize in some of the critiques, real issues that we need to deal with.
But Steve,
like Claude is very confident in the results of his studies in the effect of the
stereotype threat in general. Um,
so much so that I'm writing right now an where
I'm going to disclose every single study I've ever done,
what the results are and put the data up for everybody to look at. Wow. Um,
I will admit to the question will research practices that I've done,
um, and be as forthcoming and honest with everything in my own lab.
In addition to doing that, I've entered into an adversarial collaboration.
It's called,
which just means he's going to do a big scale reproduction study
with people who have serious doubts about whether stereotype threat is real.
You know, I can't say ahead of time what my reaction will be.
I think what I can promise is that I will take the findings very seriously and I
will do my utmost not to be defensive about them.
Are you nervous about this itself? No. I mean the stakes are pretty high.
No, no. I mean, you know a what you mean the stakes are high.
I mean, I'm a full professor. I have tenure.
What are the real stakes for me in this? Not really much,
but, well,
not everyone in the field is handling these kinds of niggling doubts. Um,
so, well,
there are so many pieces of evidence that things are not, all right.
This again is Michael intellect, the professor from Toronto
to be faced with the, the, the, the probability,
the likelihood that all this might've been for not,
or much of it might've been for nod. It's, you know, it's unsettling, right?
It's, it's, it's a loss of meaning.
[inaudible]
you know, W was, I was, I doing good work was a contribute to knowledge. Um,
I was, I, part of the problem was I tasting, you know,
signal was I tasting noise.
[inaudible]
I mean, I think the effect is, you know, it might be there,
but it might be so small as to not be, not be meaningfully important.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that's interesting. I don't know. It's hard to know where to stand on this.
Well, one thing that you know,
you should make clear is that stereotypes can be really damaging. I mean,
having someone tell you you suck at something when you're under the gun to do
it. Um, that's always gonna you know, that's going to have an effect.
I guess the question is, yeah, how you know,
what effect exactly and when and how and what can you do about it and,
and those things feel like maybe,
I guess it feels like the part of me that wanted this to be a kind of very
simple fix that would work everywhere and sort of save the world. You know,
that part is really, you know, feeling a little bit of,
a lot like worrying that this whole thing is shrinking on me a bit. But yeah,
totally. It does feel that weirdly, like we're all growing up a little bit.
Is it, you kind of just have to walk away from the, those big simple promises,
you know? Yeah.
Maybe that's exactly what you need in order to be able to find the smaller
places where you can have an effect. You know, right here,
right now with this person trying to do this particular thing.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
producer editors. So on wheeler thanks to him. Thanks.
So Dan Engber this piece was produced by Simon Adler and Amanda Aronchick.
Okay. I guess we should go. Yeah, I'm Jad Abumrad. I remember Krill,
which thanks for listening.